[Musique]
je sui sébastien thomas ses dirigeants
de protéger environnement société
spécialisée dans l'étanchéité barger
membrane liés aux ouvrages de protection
de l'environnement
[Musique]
aujourd'hui le principe c'est de
recueillir l'eau dont des systèmes de
récupération pour éviter de polluer le
milieu naturel
nous réalisons l'étanchéité de bassins
d'eaux pluviales stockage d'eau soit
doré seulement routiers soit stockage
d'eaux industrielles
on a aussi une activité dans les centres
d'enfouissement technique ce qu'on
appelle vulgairement les décharges
d'ordures ménagères
on travaille principalement dans le nord
et l'ouest de la france sur ses
activités là et on travaille aussi
depuis 20 ans à tahiti en nouvelle
calédonie dans l'enfouissement de
déchets principalement celles des grands
trous
terrassé par un terrassier nous ont bien
appliqué une géotextile de protection et
ensuite une géo membrane d'étanchéité
[Musique]
avant de créer mon entreprise j'ai été
conducteur de travaux chez eurovia
pendant sept ans 93 de nuit et j'ai
travaillé deux ans dans l'étanchéité
juste avant dans une petite filiale
d'eurovia la nature shalit est juste
avant de créer mon entreprise
[Musique]
les défis de demain c'est maintenir une
activité soutenue par rapport à la crise
duc le vide depuis une dizaine d'années
nous constatons quelques difficultés
dans le recrutement de personnel
technique notamment de chefs de chantier
soudeur bien que nous les informions en
interne
notre défi pour les années à venir c'est
maintenir un personnel qualifié bien
payés et en même temps de développer
notre activité commerciale
[Musique]